bonjour merci d'être en direct avec
monde rappelle en fait le quatrième
accord de ce type conclu le royaume uni
est ce que la france n'est pas un peu en
retard non je pense que ce qui est il
faut savoir réfléchir avant de décider
et ses pouvoirs parce que il ya une peur
absolument invraisemblable propagée par
la plupart des médias qu'il faut faire
n'importe quoi
je ne suis pas contre les vaccins mais
encore faut-il que le vaccin soit d'une
part sur qui ressent danger et d'autre
part efficace et pour cela
comme tout traitement quel qu'il soit en
médecine il faut qu'on puisse juger de
ses avantages et de ses risques
éventuels
or se précipiter pour acheter un vaccin
qui n'existe toujours pas me paraît
complètement fou est ce que vous achetez
vous une voiture qui n'existe pas sans
plan ça me paraît incroyable
donc là les gouvernements agissent par
peur qu'ils ont fait d'ailleurs pour
imposer le shutdown en angleterre parce
que le confinement en france le
confinement à venir s'en séparer les
gens malades des gens sains ce qui a
aggravé les réelles et la mortalité
d'épidémie
donc je dirais wait and see attendons et
voyons les résultats objectifs de ces
vaccins avant de l'acheter et justement
on en est où dans cette course au vaccin
on a l'impression que tout le monde est
à gary via des pastels un peu partout à
travers le monde concrètement on en est
où est ce que 2020 ou 2025 il y aura un
vaccin contre le coc vite 19
alors moi je ne suis pas prophète donc
je ne peux pas vous dire quand est ce
qu'il ya un vaccin ce que je simplement
je peux dire c'est qu'il faut se méfie
énormément des vaccins fait dans la
précipitation
je pense qu'en france on a été quand
même très échaudés par le vaccin contre
la grippe h1n1
on nous avait présenté comme locaux
vides commune et pandémie qui allait
tuer
des milliers de personnes des centaines
de milliers de personnes quelle terrible
on a acheté 80 millions de vaccins ça
nous a coûté deux milliards mais la
risée de l'europe
ce vaccin n'a pas fonctionné et 100 le
vaccin
nous avons eu un nombre ridicule de bord
de la chaîne
donc soyons prudents nous ne croyons pas
n'importe quoi
alors pour locaux vides 19 il faut
savoir que le précédent peuvent ils
avaient fait l'objet a été l'objet d'un
vaccin par sanofi et ce vaccin n'a
jamais été commercialisé parce qu'il
n'avait aucun intérêt parce que
l'épidémie a disparu définitivement
donc je pense qu'à acheter mettre des
milliards ar qu'actuellement on est dans
une situation financière de 6 mois
pouvant table mettre des milliards sur
un hypothétique vaccin qui peut être
existe aura peut-être pas personne n'en
sait rien me paraît complètement fou
alors selon vous il faut faire quoi
alors il faut demander aux gens de faire
de vraies études et d'acheter de vaccin
s'il marche il faut deux choses il faut
d'une part que le vaccin soit efficace
et non toxique et d'autre part que
l'épidémie reviennent alors personne ne
peut prétendre que l'épidémie va revenir
actuellement nous casse les oreilles de
reprise de l'épidémie city plaisanterie
je regardais ce matin les résultats
officiels
d'une part de l' oms et d'autre part de
santé publique france et qu'est ce qu'on
voit sur les santé publique france qui
est quand même le problème de notre pays
c'est que depuis deux mois il ya de plus
de malades ya plus l'entrée en
réanimation il ya extrêmement peu de
morts qui sont nos morts de jadis qui
ont traîné en quelque sorte et d'autre
part si on regarde la surmortalité café
el kobbi 2009 en france par rapport aux
grippes et bien elle est restée
inférieure à la ville de hong kong
donc pourquoi est-ce qu'on nous enfermer
de manière militaire comme en italie et
de lorsqu'on regarde également à la
mortalité d'après le msa la mortalité
mondiale
il se trouve que les grottes quatre
grands pays qui ont confiné à la
française c'est à dire de manière
aveugle et policière l'italie la france
l'espagne la belgique sont tous les
quatre dans le top 6 des mortalité les
plus élevés au niveau mondial donc ces
gens qui nous ont dit qu'il fallait
qu'on fini et que ça allait nous sauver
et qu'ils on se retrouve avoir tué nos
vieux de manière invraisemblable et
d'être parmi les pires résultats de
mortalité au monde
comment pourrait-on les croire quand une
vigile faux papiers mais si je vous
comprends bien ça veut dire que
l'épidémie que l'on traverse
actuellement n'est pas si grave en tout
cas qu on voudrait nous faire croire
ah ben ça c'est ce point qui le dit
relisez oms
regardez les statistiques de la nes
regarder ce que dit l'om est sur les
épidémies de grippe annuelle n'est
grippe banale la grippe banale ou un
minimum de 20 millions de malades de
malades jeudi pas de gens infectés avec
un simplement de sérologie positive
jeudi des gens qui ont de la fièvre qui
sont fatigués qui sont dit de rester au
lit
donc au niveau mondial une vie banale
annuel c'est 20 millions de gens très
malades et entre 300 et 650 mille morts
actuellement le coc u19 dont on nous
rabat les oreilles depuis quatre mois
comme de la nouvelle peste n'a touché
que 16 millions et demi de personnes
dans le monde et compte environ 600
mille morts donc des chiffres qui ne
sont pas très différente d'habitat des
habituels donc ce n'est pas la peste
comme certains ministres ont osé le dire
à la dédiant c'est une épidémie
saisonnière qui a la particularité
d'être une grille plus méchant que
d'habitude ça c'est vrai les gens du nom
fait on était plus fatigué qui comme la
grippe habituelle tous les vieux et pour
le reste très peu les enfants par tuer
avoir fermé les écoles alors que les
enfants ne peuvent pas transmettre la
maladie
contrairement à l'avis un abri des
enfants entrant fait son responsable de
30% des transmissions mais pour locaux
vinyle enfants ne transmette jamais la
mélodie ou infirmer les écoles à tort
les enfants ne transmettent pas là mali
il n'attrape à l'école on le savait pas
pas en vouloir à nos gouvernements
d'avoir fermé les écoles mais en tout
cas on pourrait dire
à l'école sans risque et sans précaution
particulière c'est tout à fait ridicule
bon d'autre part il ya plein de gens qui
appose de la propagande mensongère je
lis bien mensongère des médias ont peur
d'attraper le virus des gens qui ont
moins de 50 ans il n'y a pas de morts
parmi les moins de 50 ans enfin il y en
a quelques-uns et lionel pelchat jamais
il y en a eu quelques-uns et moins que
la titanic même nom et s'est laissée là
il faut comparer aux autres et qui dénie
situe dépit de lui une véritable
épidémie qui fait des malades et des
morts mais pas plus que la grippe était
la seule différence et elle est réelle
ces cas là qu habituellement la grippe
et eu beaucoup dans les pays
sous-développés afrique en asie sable et
là elle a touché surtout les bips très
développé ça c'est une différence réelle
importance
elle a tout fit semblant parce que ces
pays très développés ont des moyens de
transports publics qui sont des vrais
régulateur avis russie qui ont propagé
le virus à la vitesse qu'on a pu voir
mais en dehors de ça au niveau mondial
c'est pas pire que nous faisons est
beaucoup moins grave que la grippe de
hong kong pour lequel on n'avait pas
confiné il ya alors si l'on tient compte
dans une mesure en tout traitement font
peser le pour et le contre
on a confiné on a eu finalement autant
de morts puisqu'on est nous qui avons
confiné comme des fous avons beaucoup
plus de morts que taiwan que singapour
que le japon vit lequel au japon ça
démarre mais japon ils ont six morts par
million d'habitants en france sous sol à
480 par million d'habitants ils ont pas
confiner les japonais donc le
confinement a été une meilleure valeur
stratégique parce que prise par la peur
on a eu peur de ce qu'ils avaient
raconté 2ms et neil ferguson qui nous a
dit si vous confie n'est pas à 100 db
pin
je suis obligé de vous couper on
arrivait à la fin cette interview manque
un peu de temps merci pour votre analyse
votre avis je rappelle que vous êtes
chirurgien et statisticiens